FMA cour filmed this video under the
rubble of a six story building in Kahan
Mar Southern
turkey her family was trapped alongside
her her final wish that the money she
had raised for a family in need be paid
out if she
died fatma's husband and two of their
sons survived last year's devastating
earthquakes but 12-year-old Bal was
killed now they live in a new house with
quick resistant foundations provided by
the government FMA says her grief hasn't
eased the past year has gone by so
quickly like a dream usually we wouldn't
stay away from our children for a day
now we've been separated from our son
forever we have good living conditions
the government gave us this house
furniture and everything of course many
people helped out as well but are we
truly happy we aren't with 30,000
businesses nearly
175,000 people worked here before the
disaster lot Ser earthquakes killed
12,000 people in kaham Maraj and damaged
nearly 70% of the buildings many of
those who survived moved to nearby Towns
now slowly but surely the city is
regaining its reputation as a commercial
and IND
Hub okes had been a barber all his life
when his shop was damaged he tried
working in other cities but didn't stay
long he says his heart was always in
Kahan Maraj he moved back and rebuilt
the shop with his own
money along with his neighbors he's
helping others in
need we were five or six people working
at the barber shop our clients were
construction workers during the day
there was nothing to eat so I thought
why don't I open a restaurant I don't
think anyone should leave People Like Us
have revived the city if you fight you
have everything the government moved
quickly to provide housing to the
hundreds of thousands of families who
lost their homes in the Quakes but it's
a major initiative and authorities Say
it'll take
time despite the challenges people
likees are determined to do their best
to restore their communities cam coo El
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer